*Clap*
OAHH
AHHH
*Monkey Pewds*
MEME - REVIEW EVERYONE
Welcome back to the greatest show on the goddamn planet, the show where we... What are we doing here again? *crickets*
Review memes that's right everyone. Leave your entries in the-  *Editor notices oopsie* I'm a bit of a memester
I like memes what can I say? I wasn't cool in high school, but now I know all the subculture on the internet.
Take that liberals. Meme review everyone first meme. That's right
Don't spoil endgame, please guys please
No spoilers of end game in the comments, please guys. Everyone is so dumb
Okay, dumb and dumb
If you want to stop someone from doing something you can't just go:
"Don't do that" cuz that inevidently leaves that there's gonna be someone going
*screeching from the bowels of hell*
AnTmAN diEs
What you need to do to counter the endgame spoilers, it's just spread a bunch of lies.
Okay, you need to just start spamming everywhere all these random
scenarios that could happen in end game like "Ant-man marries Dr. Phil",
"Elon Musk kills Thanos" start dropping these comments everywhere and eventually people won't know what the actual
spoilers are because there are spoilers everywhere. Okay, that's how you counter spoilers. You dummies. Now;
Well there's of course already been theories out there like Thanos and ant-man and there's plenty of more to come out of it
Look at this spoiler
That's a spoiler right there. "Man in Hong Kong
reportedly beaten up outside cinema for leaking Avengers: Endgame spoilers
Jesus Christ people take this seriously. Now, of course
I've never heard of this website, and I never seen any- this photo could be taken out of any context,
but I'm gonna take it as a fact. This does put a smile on my face.
"She's wearing the stones!?! Brie's straight up telling us Carol's gonna put the Infinity Gauntlet and end Thanos' ass."
I thought it said she's gonna put her hand IN Thanos' ass. See that's another theory. That could be
definitely possible in- Jesus Christ, this is literally me if I saw Brie Larson,
*lul* in real life
The only Brie I like is the one on my sandwiches
*Awkward silence*
Is that- does that joke translate to English? That's right. It's brie cheese, that's right it translates-
Dr. Strange: "I looked forward in time, I saw 14 million 'n 605 futures." Iron Man: "Why the frick would you count them?"
*Bruh sound effect #2* Dr. Strange be like *Bruh sound effect #2*
"What if we use 100% of the brain?"
"Don't watch End Game. It contains a lot of spoilers for End Game." Damn
I take back what I said that everyone is a ball of dung. Geez, some people know
My door is ringing.
*sponsor*
Now, where were we? That's right End Game spoilers. "Thanos in endgame: *Speaks*
Memers: "Write that down, write that down!""
That's right I can't wait for all the new Thanos memes
Again, I never saw the last Marvel movie. I'm not planning to see this one
I just need to figure out the plot through memes and it makes it way more interesting,
okay. That's the real way to avoid spoilers! "End Game spoilers, People who don't care about the movie." That's right
Wait other people exist like that? Those such as me? "I haven't watched age of Ultron yet
just please don't spoil it!" "Therapist: "Minecraft Dr. Phil Thanos isn't real. He can't hurt you."
Minecraft Dr. Phil Thanos:" My god, who would have thought?
"Mark Zuckerberg accidentally reading endgame spoilers while looking through peoples' conversations:"
Oh damn, that good old Mark Zucc meme's still alive. Man, I wish- Zucc please come back
Okay, we need more memes. It was beautiful, please - uh - come back. "I killed a dragon. I trained a dragon I raised a dragon
Woah there buddy. This could have been an end game spoiler. You need to be more careful.
Yikes, that was close.
"Mom, Can we watch Avengers: Endgame?"
"MOM: We have Avengers at home"
"Avengers: Endgame at home:"
BibleMan????
See, this is the movie i wanna see.
I want to see is that real Bible man power source Bibleman
Bible man - holy shi
Bible man... is real. Bible man defeating shadows of doubt
Movie: "Eunice"
"Not stop your parents from arguing but talking to God." He kind of looks like Goose Wayne doesn't he?
I need to watch this. I will unironically watch this. All right
End game spoiler gets a 2 I don't know what to tell you
They're just very popular because it's relevant, but ehhh no one's gonna care next week, but there you go everyone. Next meme!
Want some? Ha ha, the dog says quieres.
"Want some?" Pewds -> Goddamnit
Why is this a meme??? It makes me mad!!
Damn the edits tho!
Oh my God
What the hell is this?
Does it have any context?
Hi how r u?
What u want
I want u to b friends
no
why :(
cuz were evil
*they hit him*
aaaaa im gonna become more evil than u
wait and see
The time someone needs to become more evil later
hi sons of a bitch
u came for another beating?
i came for revenge
pls dont kill us
*shots in mexican*
jaja they died
say no to bullin
Note: all the grammar mistakes in the subtitles were made in purpose to replicate the same mistakes that were written on purpose in the original video
Wow Spanish memes are so good!!! Wow, 10 out of 10.
That's all you need for memes these days, just quieres.
No, no. Okay actually... yes cute
Whyyyyy
God damn it
Quieres?
Hey no, no, no
Of course.
Wow, he's so dreamy
Thank you. Yes, will hit the fat blunt. God damn it. I hate this meme it gets zero. I'm sorry
I don't know what to tell you
NEXT MEME!
Can you guess what the next meme is? We've already sort of spoiled it? That's right everyone.
*Reads meme*
It's a bit of an older meme but it still needs to be reviewed, goddammit. I've been on holiday
What do you want from me? Why is this a meme that just trascends all language and all culture?
Everyone can understand this meme anyone that grew up at the age of McDonald's knows the feeling
When they say we have food at home, and you know exactly what that means. It's not gonna be good
There's never ever been a time where they say we have food at home and the food the meal is actually better than McDonald's
Can we eat at home? No, there's food at McDonald's
Yeah, I guess that's the point but you got happy meal at least then come on
Can we please buy the new Nintendo switch? We already have consoles at home
Consoles, I'd hope you don't get it mom
Mom, am I beautiful?
Like a prince the Prince. Thanks mom
Mom can I get a dolphin? No, we'd have a dolphin at home dolphin at home is dead mom
Jesus Christ. Elon, stop please. me at the store mom. Can I have minecraft?
Mom, no, we have games at home games at home - Fortnite
Basically when your mom passes McDonald's and says there's food at home
It's funny because everyone can relate to these everyone has been in that moment and it hurts
It really hurts and I feel your pain smash you like on this video if you feel pain right now, can I have sex?
No, we already have sex at home
alabama'
Feel like Alabama. You have a lot of explaining to do. Alright, there's a lot of memes trying to defame Alabama over here
We need Alabama to stand up for themselves. Come on, Alabama. What do you got, huh?
If you're from Alabama, I need to hear some excuses right frickin now or else
Alabama is gonna be
Alabama
Dama, dama, you know what? I mean me. Can we stop and get food mom we have food at home food ed
Oh, hey, that looks pretty good. I'll have a snack of that. I have a little below that
Cooked banana with some Cheerios and some mom. Can we get a PewDiePie?
We have a PewDiePie at hom- hey, I guess I was wrong
There is a better there is better snacks at home cuz yummy yummy yum, yum, you know Jesus Christ
Mom, can we stop at McDonalds? No, we have food at home my gosh mom
Can we have some moto moto mom? We have moto moto at home moto moto at home
Well, goddamn, I guess I was wrong again where there is a better version at home. God. Damn. It me at store mom
Can I have a Ricardo mom? No, we have a Ricardo at home Ricardo at home. Wait a minute
This meme is literally the Netflix adaptation mean that's right. I scooby-doo one wielded it
It's the same name basically mom. Can we have Marzia?
Mom: No, we have Marzia at home. Marzia at home. That's right. Everyone this meme
gets aaa- ahhh
It hurts
People have noticed. You know,
We always talk about the one meme that will transcend all memes that one meme that will rule them all
We don't quite know what it is yet, but we will find it but there's been one meme
lurking in the background
It's been sneaking around
causing destruction making illusions
Making us think that it isn't there when it's been there all along. Yes. That's right. I'm talking about
Skyrim memes everyone the one mean that just can't be killed you expand toises can never be quenched
Skyrim memes it just can't die cuz all memes will die eventually
But skyrim memes so far have not died for so long
So let's go through some of my favorite Skyrim memes because they're funny
So I'm sitting on the sofa with my son watching TV and he hears he got a text on his phone
That he left in the kitchen. So he goes to get his phone and it's it's a text from me
Please bring the chips and a Diet Pepsi on your way back
Illusion hundred speech hundred destruction hundred
absolutely incredible
McDonald's employee fired for placing his mixtape in children's Happy Meals. Merchant *laughs*
you've unlocked in your skill tree. In your
Opinion. What's the height of stupidity?
Anakin how tall are you?
destruction: one hundred!
burglar an Oak Hill Community couple discovered a thief in their home
Saturday after a man told a joke and heard her laugh upstairs. Sneak: ZERO! This is hilarious
I played elderscrolls blaze looked at the video and Todd Howard is standing right behind me. I had no flippin idea sneak
100 Todd Howard that sneaky son of a snake
I love these. Boy, 10, steals parents car to visit grandparents 68 miles away. Then tells police he is a dwarf
Who has forgotten his license sneak hundred speech hundred?
illusion one 100 my god some people just have
Maximized it all nice earmuffs Potter. Did your mom make them for you?
Destruction 100 he doesn't have a mom. His mom is dead
Hey wanna flip if you want a floor buy one, but if you want a Kuenn earn her.
How much for you then? Oh
Wow when Skyrim hundred tablets have lasted longer than anything else and nobody says anything
Sneak 100 meme review ten, babe! Nah, nine. I'm sorry
That's it for this week's meme review. Hope you guys had fun and if you did
Clap your hands and I'll see you guys next week, buh
Tuber simulator. It's now so relevant that it's got a brand new mini game
cranium drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more of
course, there is new knowledge perks new quests and new pics links and
guys
like